the eternals is definitely a very  ambitious film it's beautiful isn't it  you've got 10 new characters it spans 7  000 years the scope and the scale of it  is is huge  what excites me the most is the the  World building the design yeah Kirby's  Comics are great inspirations  what we really wanted to do was start  fresh with whole new characters new  story lines but actually go back to some  of the deepest richest mythology in all  of Marvel Comics  each on my cars come from different  backgrounds and they come from different  life experiences  so I'm trying to see how much of this  character that's already in this person  we shall we  assess to shoot more of this on  practical locations which is challenging  but it's all in service of an aesthetic  that's totally different you hear that  the impact eternals will have on the MCU  will be nothing less than redefining the  Cinematic Universe entirely  [Music]  thank you